uh so first that definition
so what is a dynamic web application
well it's not static first of all HTML
views are rendered on demand given the
state from a database so it's a full
stack application
um for all the way from the data
persistence layer to the presentation
layer on the front if you're building an
API that's a dynamic web application so
it doesn't have to necessarily be HTML
though I'm going to talk a lot about
what those views look like this could
easily be a Json API or an XML API
um and Frameworks for these types of
applications have existed for a long
time I believe last I checked there was
like 80 percent of the internet runs on
WordPress that is a dynamic web app
framework you'll see others here uh
Django for python larval for PHP
personal favorite Express in the node
ecosystem and uh rails and I actually
want to talk a little bit about rails
today it's where I come from as a
background developer I did a ton of
rails development back in the day these
days I'm I'm almost exclusively
JavaScript both on the front end and the
back end but we'll use rails to start
talking about
the traditional three-tier architecture
now this is going to be pretty familiar
to most people as MVC or model view and
controller they're a little out of order
here but I think it it tracks
um basically the data layer the
application layer and this is where
we're writing most of our code in these
three Tiera architectures and then of
course presentation so that is what the
user or the consumer ends up seeing
so uh in the framework inside rails I've
gone ahead and annotated these here with
those Ruby classes we used data was the
active record the controller was an
action controller and the presentation
was an action View this is uh what I
want to call The Logical architecture so
how do developers
um reason about the thing that they're
building usually we would divide up this
in our head
and it made it very easy in previous
talks today even touched on this that
rails was very approachable even if
you've never been a part of that
business model or that product you could
jump into a repository and understand
based on conventions what this thing is
doing whether you understand the code
line by line This logical architecture
gave a set of developers if you knew the
stack
a way to Dive Right into an application
but it does differ from the rails
physical architecture at least the rails
physical architecture at scale so as we
started deploying rails apps we could
quickly realize these things needed to
scale horizontally with all that good
traffic we were getting a rails
applications were starting to fall down
um and this is you know we can talk
about Ruby performance versus python or
whatever but I think any three-tier
application at a certain scale starts to
trip up so we started do some smart
things moving our database server out of
the appliance that actually runs a ruby
or python code we would add on other
servers like a cache server to really
increase performance and then we
multiply the number of web servers in
our stack to many many instances
depending on your scale I think you
could probably talk to some Twitter
Engineers Circa
2010 to 2012 on what they think of
scaling rails out as that company grew
of course this needed a load balancer to
help coordinate all of these resources
making sure that the users on one end
were in touch with the instance they
were supposed to be talking to and that
all that data was persisted correctly
of course we also had a CDN or content
delivery Network this was a really good
Advent for Distributing static assets
things that don't change a lot certainly
not changing on every page load
um you can think of CSS JavaScript and
images
so it did differ from our logical
architecture but as developers we were
really only concerned with that
deployment Target of those web servers
so the code we were writing every day
and likely contained inside a single
project in our Version Control was what
was going to that those web servers the
rest of it though connected was a
separate chore if we needed to tune our
load balancer or update
the database version those are separate
tasks outside of our project
so
um in some ways this was handled by
really smart tools
um Heroku particularly comes to mind
that was a revelation at the time and
still today they have an excellent
product that's going to try and handle a
lot of this for you but again it wasn't
part of what we were doing day to day
writing code in a rails infrastructure
so these traditional Dynamic apps and
I've already kind of talked about a few
of these uh issues
they had a few problems
um like I said The Logical architecture
doesn't necessarily match the things
you're physically deploying to this made
deployment kind of a moving Target you
are slow rolling out instances
um
trying to make sure your code was
literally distributed around the world
to different machines that have booted
up correctly connected to the database
correctly handled any sort of migrations
um and some of those appliances that
were attached to our web servers
were moving targets maybe somebody
changed them in the meantime
maintenance costs was pretty high and I
mean in terms of dollars and developer
hours
scaling out a traditional three-tier
application can get very spendy very
fast
not to mention all of the developer
hours sunk into patching and debugging
these things
last I think background jobs which are
required to make your application as
performant as possible
um weren't necessarily first class they
often felt bolted on our Frameworks you
know I don't want to throw any
particular framework under the bus but
several did think about them but they
often weren't attached to the code we
were writing in our main rails project
folder and probably not checked into the
same project in Version Control
so more recently we've seen other types
of tech stacks and architectures emerge
I'm sure most developers in the room
know what uh the jam stack is
and by the way I'm don't want to throw
shade at any specific stack I really
enjoy both rails and jam stack sites
I've definitely made a living from both
um but the ideals of jam sack kind of
flip that three-tier on its head it's
going to be totally static we're going
to write just a client application that
we're going to bundle up toss it on a
CDN and then ship that to each user's
device so all of that business logic
presentation is all part of an immutable
deployment meaning the deployment that's
up there is not going to change in
itself nothing on the file system is
going to change until we say that that
deployment is void and we're going to
send a new one
this approach really empowered front-end
developers and I think about the time
this Jam sack idea came out I was really
focused on front-end web development so
it was really empowering for me to
essentially Outsource my back end
a huge crop of services
um popped up
seemingly overnight to offer you as a
developer all sorts of features for your
application so you could add
authentication with auth zero you could
swipe a credit card with stripe
these sort of services to add
functionality are still popping up all
the time
so going back to that idea of logical
architecture and this is how
specifically developers think about the
thing they're building the nice part
about Jam sack was all I had to worry
about was The Client app the thing that
was bundled up that HTML CSS and
JavaScript
that were and I would create a single
artifact and shoot it up to the cloud
and then it connected to any number of
apis this is really easy to reason about
because for the most part I'm only
writing in one uh programming language
JavaScript my markup is HTML or css
excuse me there goes the voice
um so but what was this like when we hit
the physical architecture when we
actually deploy it into the real world
or the cloud
um what does that end up looking like
well
you can see on the left side here I've
sort of exploded that that single API
into what it actually is which is uh any
number of services that provide all
those features in the middle is my code
that likely has for each service I plan
to talk to additional code luckily that
is all sent from a CDN so it should be
very performant it's still really easy
to reason about this it's just starting
to get a bit complex and maybe even
problematic with all the different
connections that are outside of our
control
so specifically talking about that
deployment Target and the the the
artifact we own as developers and how it
relates to everything else we really
only control that uh that client-side
application and this is a good thing for
the most part I mean it's simple enough
to think about like I said but these
other services are uh not in our Version
Control or in our control at all so if
one falls down isn't able to respond God
forbid there's an API shift that no one
told us about it can get a little bit uh
problematic
so
Jam sack also has its trade-offs um I
think the most important one is that it
makes us beholden to our client devices
so that is the the things our customers
and our users are using be it their
phone or their MacBook or whatever uh
we're unsure what the performance is
like on their device also we're unsure
what the JavaScript runtime they're
using is I mean it's not as bad as back
in the day like I was saying with ie9
through six that I have to support but
uh it's still not simple the other one
is the network environment do they have
a good connection uh did one thing drop
before another did is there a race
condition in the network we can't always
be sure about that
and uh
another big one they're not Dynamic by
default and what I mean is dynamic being
where the initial state of the
application is based on live data a lot
of the jamsack apps that are shipped
um they're they start with no knowledge
of where they are or who they are or
what's going on so we need them to boot
up on the client figure out the world
around them and then start running code
so while that complex ecosystem of
services and features is an advantage it
can also be a disadvantage because it
leads to a lot of tooling and a lot of
plugins to sort of wrangle all of this
together it ends up being a lot of
stitching and glue code to hold it
together
so you may have heard
um in the
area of energy economics there's
something called The Rebound effect I
won't read the definition from Wikipedia
here but it boils down to that you don't
always get as much out of a system that
you would expect given a new technology
so what does that mean well has we start
engaging in new technologies that have
an expected return of gains because they
are utilized more we are going to see a
diminished amount of return on those
gains so it's essentially a fancier way
of the diminishing return rule or an 80
20 Rule now this isn't necessarily one
to one with web applications so my
colleague at begin.com Simon
he came up with and coined the
JavaScript rebound effect
where the expected gains from a new
JavaScript framework are always less
because the amount of JavaScript being
deployed to the client the additional
JavaScript diminishes The Beneficial
effects of the new technology and in
some cases can actually make things
worse so basically as you're solving
more and more problems with JavaScript
you ship more JavaScript and your gains
are diminished from what they would be
now that's not to say they're completely
negated it just doesn't lead to that
large impact you were hoping for
so this kind of brings up our new idea
functional web app we call it fwa for
short I'm not sure that's that many less
syllables but it works for us you can
check out our website fwa.dev it's sort
of a white paper type example or a
website and I've pulled the definition
for fwa here functional web app is an
architectural pattern for building web
applications and apis it empowers
developers with the flexibility of
dynamic full stack applications so think
of those the rails apps and the dynamic
web apps I was talking about before
paired with the ease of scaling of the
static website so the inherent power of
a jam sack website powered by a CDN and
static assets
so it's a whole new approach based on
both of those ideas it's HTML first so
that every response is dynamically
rendered with personalized results for
the state of that application this is a
huge Boon for accessibility as well
because we're shooting down a whole
rendered stateful document to the client
every single reply
it's Cloud function Centric so it's a
many small linked apps working together
rather than a larger Tangled monolithic
one
um
Cloud functions is a specific term we've
chosen here
it I would say in some sense it's
synonymous with serverless or
microservices but both of those terms
we've seen a little bit of confusion
around so we've kind of settled in the
Middle Ground here for cloud function
importantly fwas also have an on-demand
database so it's a full stack
application it needs that database in
our case since they're on demand and
managed they Auto scale so there's no
sockets or connection pooling plus
they're just wicked fast
uh last declarative deployment so we
have explicitly defined our
infrastructure as code you'll see this
referenced as IAC
this leads to what we call like the
three facets of an fwa Cloud functions a
managed database and deterministic
deployment
so there's no real framework here it's
adhering to these three principles
can make your application a functional
web app
so going forward I want to talk a little
bit about The Logical architecture we
touched on this with rails and we talked
about it with Jam sack and you'll notice
the logical architecture for an fwa is
actually pretty similar to a jam sack in
that it's essentially a two-tier
application we have a data access layer
for persistence and we have our view and
controller code our application logic
lives in a cloud function and data in
the database it's really easy to think
about and reason about your application
this way as you're building
and now I know what you're thinking
you're looking at this single Cloud
function and it says View and controller
code under there and you're worried how
do I shove all of this code and a lot
it's going to be a mess and you're not
wrong it is a lot of code but we
actually divide it across
a dozen or dozens of cloud functions
so that leads into the physical
architecture and there's definitely a
departure here from that logical
architecture of an fwa but as you can
see what I've done is I've sort of
outlined two groups with a gray box and
in the purpose of that is to illustrate
that these are hands-off for us or at
least the environments are I can't shell
into the box at Amazon that runs my
lambdas that's their job and it's the
same with the database it's somebody
else's job to make sure this thing
scales out it has the availability it's
got the security patches it's it's ready
to go all I need to do is provide the
data and provide the functions
you'll notice that I have many Cloud
functions here and they respond to
different protocols I realize that
font's probably pretty small to see but
one of them says HTTP another has a
websocket protocol I've got scheduled
cron jobs I've got
Pub sub event cues
the other part is the client and we're
still using a CDN here that should
probably be in a gray box as well
because in theory all we're doing is
publishing our static files so that
they're available to the client that
gets responses from our Cloud functions
that's part of why I left the HTML file
out of the client here because HTML is
being rendered dynamically by the server
and sent to the client whereas our
static assets like images and JavaScript
are being fetched from a CDN
so let's put those two side by side on
the left I've got the jam stack sort of
rearranged it here and on the right is a
rearranged functional web app looking
specifically at the deploy targets so
when I say deploy Target I mean what
what is the thing that our code is
concerned about
and on the left
it's just that small section of our
client and like I said this isn't a bad
thing this is actually really simple for
a developer but it does put a lot of
things outside of the realm of our
control
on the right side with functional web
app because we've declared our entire
infrastructure as code because we've
configured that ahead of time we're
going to maintain control of all of
those resources and our cloud provider
is going to provision them according to
the instructions we give so in that way
it's a versioned artifact of our code
base
so some functional web app superpowers
this is my favorite slide I uh I think
that functional web apps are super
powerful you can build a full stack
Dynamic web application batteries
included with this Paradigm and I can
personally attest to the developer
happiness having built web applications
in many ways for many platforms this is
way less ceremony and configuration and
configuration of configuration I get to
just build things and ship them
last it's also very accessible and I
mean that from both sides so it's
accessible to a variety of developers
but it also creates a application that
is very accessible to end users
so the fwa approach
um
is for developers of any experience
level because you can create Cloud
functions as simple or as complex as you
want you can create one or 147 it's
really up to you how you want your
application to work and then of course
since we're always rendering HTML
or valid markup in real time with State
attached already that's going to be more
performant over the wire and it's going
to send a fully
readable digestible SEO uh optimized uh
view down to the consumer
but I'd be remiss if I didn't mention
some drawbacks so just like the other
two approaches there are definitely
drawbacks here I think the one you're
going to hear most common or at least
right off the bat are cold starts
what's a cold start a cold start is when
a cloud function like a Lambda or a
worker something hasn't been called in a
while so it actually scales down to zero
it's asleep it needs to boot up
we found ways to mitigate this and it's
something that both tooling projects and
providers vendors are working actively
to solve we found that in the worst case
if you're looking at a one second cold
start if you keep your function under
about five megabytes and you're thinking
wow if I look at my node modules right
now or my my gem folder it's just huge
the bundle we find that actually as you
start to break your project
uh into its logical pieces into its own
cloud functions you'd be surprised how
small those that could code footprint
can actually be
the other thing is the database story is
still evolving we have database
appliances available uh from vendors
like Dynamo that are
super fast and available but it's always
nice to have third-party options I've
seen and had particular interest in a
few lately namely Planet scale fauna and
cockroachdb are are looking at that
manage manage database as a service
the next thing I've heard and I run into
this a bit declarative infrastructure as
code can be a barrier to entry and I
agree with this to a point because it's
definitely a new paradigm
who wants to learn about infrastructure
I mean that's devops job right I'm sure
there's devops people who love that um
but it's not for me but I've made a note
here hold my keyboard I'm going to show
you in a few minutes how you can do it
too uh last and I think this is a big
one and it's definitely a viable concern
for organizations building this way uh
you're looking at potential lock-in as
your relinquish control of those
machines in those environments to a
vendor it means you were probably stuck
with them for a little while but in our
experience picking a single cloud
provider going all in with that provider
is worth the risk of maybe having to
rewrite later if your cloud provider
shuts down
when is AWS shutting down probably not
anytime soon
so I wanted to give a quick glance at
like what's the ecosystem like right now
what's the tooling like and who's doing
this in the real world so on the left
side I've got a list of tools formats
and providers that help build
applications this way now you can build
other types of applications with these
same tools but I mean these are
particularly tuned for functional web
apps at the top is architect
um
it's an open source project that deploys
to AWS it's what I work on but there's
something similar called bicep for Azure
AWS has their own toolings and I've been
particularly excited about things coming
out of network fly and cloudflare as
well
plus if you've been keeping up with Dino
they've got a new service called Dino
deploy that's also really exciting
as far as functional web apps in the
wild I think a lot of case studies and a
lot of Advocates will point to the BBC
as a really standout sort of serverless
application I doubt they called it a
functional web app when they were
building it a few years ago but they
deliver most of their web content this
way you'll notice a few other big brands
on the list but at the bottom there is
begin.com that's who I work for
we help people deploy and architect uh
application or functional web app
without the need for an AWS account and
begin.com itself is a functional web app
and it runs in this same way
okay so let's put a little code on the
screen
this is a short configuration file it's
totally theoretical but it's written in
a format we call Arc so it's just a DOT
Arc file it's basically a project
manifest where I outline the resources I
intend to provision for my project it's
a really good like little summary of
what my application does so this one is
a theoretical blog app it's pretty easy
to read I've even added a few comments
to say
uh to show how Okay this static
declaration is going to create an S3
bucket here are three HTTP lambdas that
are going to sit behind an API Gateway
and finally I've got a dynamodv cable to
store the posts for my blog
so next I want to get into each one of
these sections and types of
configuration I'm actually going to toss
out this blog example because I've got a
new one
um for a theoretical functional web app
for 200 okay and we're thinking like
2023 registrations right uh so let's
walk through what that would take to
build an fwa with architect
um again at the top we've named our
project fwa 200 okay that's going to
help
um AWS form a or create a cloud
formation stack don't worry if you don't
know what that is I honestly didn't
either it's going to all be created and
provisioned for you by architect
again we've set up a static bucket in
this case we've configured it to use the
local public folder assets and we're
going to go ahead and fingerprint those
assets meaning they will uh we will
modify their file name in real time
on deployment so that we can easily
invalidate the caching later
next and this is usually when I jump
into an architect project this is like
the block of code I go to right away
what are the HTTP routes it reminds me
of a rails routes file each route is its
own Lambda function and it's all set up
behind an API Gateway so my example here
is kind of restish you can see we can
get the index we can create users we can
let a user update their own user account
we can list events we can create new
events we can update events and most
importantly line 15 there
a user can presumably register for an
event
another thing I wanted to point out on
line 14 and 11 you'll notice those
colons with those slots those are
actually path parts that can be dynamic
so that similar to like a rails
framework we can pick those up
um in our Lambda handlers
so the next chunk and to be clear this
is like the second chunk of the same
file I've tried to keep the line numbers
lined up uh
Pub sub events so we can declare a set
of expected events that might occur
throughout our app and any Lambda can
publish an event in this case I've
called it new registration so presumably
somebody signs up and that post endpoint
is going to publish an event called new
registration well our listener function
is going to wait for that to happen from
a queue pick up that event and then act
on it in this case we might want to do
something like charge your credit card
send an email or even just update our
company Slack
similarly we can have scheduled jobs
these are things that run in the
background at set intervals so I've
created one here called open
registration and it's only going to
happen once a year I'm thinking so that
no admin has to get up and open up
ticket sales this thing will do it for
us but we could also do things like
every second if we wanted to
another very important block are the
tables again this is a dynamodb backed
schema here that's outlining the users
events and registrations table
now forgive me for my poor information
architecture here uh but just to show
how this works I wanted to include
primary and secondary keys so they're
also called Partition or sort keys in
Dynamo this lets us query based on those
fields but dynamodb is like a document
storage engine so we can really attach
whatever arbitrary data we want our
application wants to things like users
and events
Etc
so the last chunk of the eight of the
architect file websockets
I didn't even know Lambda can handle
websockets
um the entire life cycle so
maybe our 200 okay website needs a live
chat feature this would be a great way
to include that and keep functions to
handle each one of those events from our
clients using websockets
next database indexes this is one that's
super helpful dynamodb can be
particularly tricky to query but
creating Global secondary indexes I can
easily for example here look up users by
their email
and the last block is the AWS block this
is actually project wide but it can be
configured per function I've specified
the runtime to Ruby here because I think
it's really cool that
lambdas aren't just JavaScript you can
run Ruby go Java python
it's it's pretty slick and so with
architect you could actually make a
hybrid app where some of your things are
Java others are Python and node for your
HTTP lambdas I've also made this one
unnecessarily large it's 10 gigabytes
that's a new thing with Lambda they used
to I think the limit was 500 Megs for
temporary disk storage but it's up to 10
gigs now and the last one is one of my
favorites I can declare the architecture
now for a Lambda so I've picked arm 64
here because one arm
compute time is actually cheaper and
faster so you pay less
and then it's faster so you pay for Less
compute to get a better function it's
just a win-win we've noticed this is
really performant with Note 16.
so this is like a total of I think we've
looks like we've hit 50 lines I think
it's about 40 or so of actual code
there it is all on the right side of
your screen
um probably hard to read but the
takeaway here is this 41 lines of Arc
configuration actually generates over
1600 lines of cloud formation if you're
not familiar with AWS and cloud
formation cloud formation is basically
like the Assembly Language of the Amazon
Cloud it tells Amazon given this giant
document of information and
configuration go create a bunch of
resources for me and then I will give
you all the code that you need to put
into each of those things so this is
pretty amazing because it's so simple
just to write my application in this way
and know deterministically that it's
going to come out excuse me the same way
for cloud formation each time and that
Amazon
uh is going to create the exact same
infrastructure every time I deploy
a couple more cool features I just want
to share real quick architect has a CLI
that will actually scaffold entire
projects for you so I plug that 50 line
or so architect file
into the CLI and it generated this
folder and file structure you see on the
left side so each folder is going to
contain an index file that index file is
my Lambda so I can just start writing
code
and then have that deployed to live AWS
infrastructure now notice I even added a
shared folder I a common worry is copy
and pasting logic maybe data modeling or
other sorts of schemas across functions
well architect allows you to share code
across functions and automatically
handles that hydration for you on
deployment
the last and probably one of the coolest
things about architect is that you can
locally emulate everything I just showed
you in that architect file so we can run
an instance of dynamodb we can create an
HTTP server we can run all those
background jobs or invoke those custom
events so that our Pub sub all works
locally and we can test it out
completely before even deploying to a
staging environment
now all these cool things I've said
about Arc are not just unique to Arc a
lot of other Frameworks do this and they
deploy to other things other than AWS so
I encourage you to kind of check out the
landscape see what you like best and if
you'd like to give Arc a try definitely
do so but if you want and you don't want
to deal with getting you know your keys
from AWS and setting up all of that you
can actually go to begin.com and try out
deploying an architect app totally free
right now
um so yeah that's it for me I would say
go forth and functional web app